Judith do you believe going to jail oh
we never mentioned her that's right you
went to jail that takes balls we're
going to jail how many days were in jail
at 585 that can't be fun even the best
jailers right it was not fun when I
turned it into a reporting assignment so
it was more fun that it would have been
it's not like in Sweden where you got a
nice little apartment in jail or if
you're Martha Stewart right did you have
a cellmate and everything um many yes
yes they were crowded and it was a busy
summer did you have the top bunk or the
bottom there are no bunks no bump no no
hey thank you sweetie
you sleep on a yoga mat in a concrete
shelf it was interested let me reiterate
the pot smoker is just a character I
play do you believe going to jail to
protect your sources was worth it
absolutely and I would do it again if I
had to but I hope I don't
Jon Meacham how do you decide on the
subject of your next biography oh I
don't know it's a good question uh the
the key thing is can you find something
new to say about usually dead people and
what does it tell us about what we're
doing now is there something
illuminating about moments in the past
where things actually worked I've
written about FDR Churchill Andrew
Jackson Thomas Jefferson and now
Bush 41 and and what is it Bush 41 yeah
say I get struck blind and I can't read
your book that's the only reason I would
I can tell because we because he knows
well coma is not going to be a problem
we know that and I only have a minute to
live okay
yeah the bottom line what President are
bad a very good president the last
Eisenhower Republican and a man who did
what it took to win to obtain power but
then he did the right thing when he had
it he then was punished that was ballsy
to go back on his pledge to no new right
no new taxes read my lip right and then
I say no we got to raise taxes this is
something Republicans did they never do
no taxes is way more important than
going into debt right and the old-school
Republicans not going into debt was job
one but imagine I interviewed Obama to
do this and Wow he was he gave this
remarkable set piece and he speaks in
camera-ready copy anyway but this was a
genuine of appreciation of a president
who had put the country first imagine a
Republican president now passing major
clean air legislation signing the
Americans with Disabilities
I don't think appointing Clarence Thomas
to the Supreme Court was putting America
first you know well I would say you
judge them I would say you judge them on
the whole record and the whole record
was but that's a pretty shitty thing to
do
because that we gave David Souter we
take that one what he gave you David sue
yeah but I'm okay okay but Clarence
Thomas I mean many scholars have said he
is the least qualified person who's ever
been on the Supreme Court if he wasn't
black they wouldn't have appointed him I
don't know I don't know I know you know
everyone knows that judge I know that
they just needed a black guy when the
other black guy the one black guy on the
court left and they had they found it
with the one concern but I need to find
that document okay well
Neera what is what's at stake for
progressives in the next election be
more vague well I mean it sort of scares
me to have a Republican president we
inhale again you're looking Senate and
what's at stake cream Court will be at
stake but not just Supreme Court I mean
tax policy the whole future of the
country when you have one party how many
how many of the justices are at that
point where they could well Ruth Bader
Ginsburg is definitely moving up in
years right think it's fair to say right
um you know we've we have a number of
relatively senior Supreme Court does
right I think three could go but if
we're also talking about how fairer the
budget is tax policy all those issues
will be at stake and whether we make
progress on any issue like wages other
issues those you're all gonna be at
stake in the next election okay oh boy
these are this must be written by the
vague squad John how will history view
the Obama process are gonna die left
everyone I suspect favorably uh really
hi Jay - oh yeah I do
cuz pray Bill Clinton once said
presidents at best or remembered for two
or three things and if you you you
listen a minute ago you know you have
Health Care Act you have killing bin
Laden and you have averting a depression
I'll take that right yeah
Judith were there any dissenters in the
intelligence community who challenged
the consensus on Iraq's WMD well there
was some who emerged after the fact a
few years after the fact and sander I
doubted there were there were a couple I
mean there were fierce fights over right
over individual bits of intelligence but
when you put it all together they all
concluded that the case was overwhelming
that I I think : powell really had the
best line about that he said where were
all these people when I was making my
speech and when the president was
looking at the intelligence where were
these dissenters when we needed them and
I think well maybe Dick Cheney told them
to shut up well I guess you know lots of
Americans who dissented there are lots
of people weapons the war Michael war at
the Oscars I mean we'll just Michael
Moore were a lot of Americans and a lot
of political leaders and one of them is
no President of the United States
upcycled Moore was not in charge of
intelligence I hope that might explain
it but no he was no wasn't in charge of
intelligence there's a lot of people we
might be in a better place if he was
let's remember there were no
how could they have done worse that's
not true there actually were WMDs we're
now sickening our troops in the way
they're 5,000 that were found of the old
one it's the old munitions that the war
actually ended up opening up because we
went into war and if we talk about Iran
and other issues today
Iran has become much stronger because of
our war with Iraq well let me ask you
then why did senator Clinton but the way
she did she says it was wrong she says
in her choices she made more it was
wrong really but in real time what but
in speaking well she was one I think 28
Democrats voted for the war yeah because
she made the mistake what she says now
of the thinking the president was this
is extra my issue with the Democrats
they don't stand up for what they
believe in they are too worried about
looking this way or looking this way
Republicans create polls Democrats chase
polls and George Bush scared everybody
they're gonna do it again this time this
is gonna be close Hillary could lose it
because they will it's going to be Isis
24/7 and that's up that I promise you
that's what they're gonna run on and
Isis will of course you know accommodate
them so clay are you going to run again
um probably not in the next few cycles
you know I think I learned a lot I went
into I went into the race because I had
issues that were important to me
education fetish veterans issues my
brother's a vet and and I came out of
the race with a whole different set of
them you know gerrymandering campaign
finance things that I didn't know enough
about until I got my hands in the actual
[ __ ] and so I and they stink and so I
and so I am I am very interested in
talking about those things right up on a
farm
no I didn't armor start like that
your hands and [ __ ] a lot so I so I
think I don't know that I'll run again
right now because I don't think that
those two issues in particular are
necessarily thing but if you're not
running and you're not singing then what
well I've got a big mouth still and I'm
still able to talk about things and I
still have a platform from singing that
I can talk about them and I don't know
that you can get everything I don't know
that you can solve that campaign finance
thing or the gerrymandering thing from
the inside necessarily as easily as you
might be able to listen you you have
more effect here in this desk in what
you do every week then most politicians
do so you don't have to be and I'm not
kissing your ass because for me I love
somebody love somebody love somebody
but but you can go
if you stop singing I'll run again yeah
thank you very much thank you
you